what's up guys so risin to is just
around the corner
and should be coming out very soon but
should you wait for it and buy it well
recently there have been some leaked
specs and performance however like
always these are just rumors and
speculation and the 3 mark score could
be faked so make sure to take this with
a grain of salt but whatever rise in to
brings that out don't buy a seat for you
right now
why well I'll get to that right after I
cover the rumor expects well starting
off there is no 2900 ex rumored to come
this actually makes sense because the
1800 ex was pretty much the same as the
1700 and 1700 X so it wasn't really
worth spending over $100 more just for a
little bit clock speed the Rockies an
1800 ex has significantly dropped in
price now but even then the 1800 ex is
quite abundant however AMD may still
bring out it 2100 ex later this year
with maybe two more incentives other
than just a bit of luck speed like uh
more PCIe lanes or even more cores
anyways getting back to speculations
there is thought to be four new pinnacle
Ridge CPUs starting off the rise in 2600
which is rumored to have 60 of course
both rest and a base clock of 3.4
gigahertz and a max boost of 3.9 figures
along with 19 megabytes of cash 16 PCIe
lanes and at 65 watts while also coming
with the r8 stealth according to these
rumors all the new pinnacle Ridge CPUs
are supposed to come with their own
cooler even the X versions but that
really is quite nice because those
coolers are actually a viable option as
opposed to Intel
soft pillars next up is the rise in 520
600 X which also has 6 cores and 12
threads 19 megabytes of cache and 16
PCIe lanes however this also comes with
the rate spiral along with a base
frequency of 3.6 gigahertz and a max
boost a 4.25 year Hertz at 95 Watts so
pretty much about 5 to 6 percent boost
in the risin 5 line up a little more
would have been nice but this isn't that
bad next on is the rising 7 the risin 7
2700 is supposed to have 8 cores and 16
threads a base frequency of 3.2
gigahertz and a max frequency of 4.1
gear
along with 20 megabytes of cash and the
rates of our LED cooler at 65 watt TDP
finally the flagship 2700 X is supposed
to have bass frequency of 3.7 gigahertz
a max frequency of four point three five
gigahertz sixteen PCIe lanes and a rate
prism cooler however this does take a
hundred and five watts so that is more
than last generation of black ship
nonetheless horizon seven series doesn't
bring about a 10 percent boost and
performance over last generation so I
would say that it's worth it lasting all
these new CPUs are supposed to be part
of a 12 nanometer and manufacturing
process well anyways while he's
performing boost or nice they are not
dramatic and we really provide a really
big real-world difference so why should
you wait for these CPUs well if you can
afford these CPUs then you might as well
wait because it's really close to
release and it does bring a little bit
more performance you can save a good
amount of money is why you should
actually wait for it if you're thinking
about buying current generation rising
CPUs then even though they're cheap
right now they will probably drop even
more in price after the release of
pinnacle Ridge pretty the new CPUs are
coming out at time at the same MSRP as
current generation also the price of
current generation motherboards will
drop as well after the new generation of
motherboards come out and so you can
save money there as well also you should
wait because you may even be able to
afford next generation pinnacle Ridge is
supposed to work with current generation
motherboards so you may be able to
afford next-generation CPUs with the
money you save on be 350 motherboards
this way you would be spending the same
money as what you are right now but
getting more performance but that's
pretty much it guys
honestly just wait because you can save
some money or may even be able to for
the next generation also was how close
it is to release you might as well see
what it brings to the table before
settling on a CPU but that's all I have
for you guys right now make sure to post
what you guys are thinking it comes down
below
I read oh I read all my comments and I'm
curious as to what you guys think for
example do you think rise in to is
redundant or do you guys think it's a
nice upgrade but anyways make sure to
post you guys thinking as always if you
like this video to make sure drop a like
on this video and subscribe if you guys
loved and would like
more videos just like this but as always
until next time
[Music]